alright let's see who's next why don't
we go oh man we've got a lot of people
holding let's try the 2 to 9 area code
who's calling today from 2 to 9 and wait
can you hear me I can hear you fine
Bobby yeah what's on your mind yeah I
was calling I wanted to see how you feel
about possibly reducing or abolishing
the income tax and maybe installing land
tax like a land value tax or maybe like
some sort of pigouvian tax system such
as like carbon taxes I don't know why we
would take away I don't know why though
so we could argue the merits of any of
those taxes individually but I have seen
no reason to suggest that getting rid of
the income tax in order to do that is is
logical why why would we do so like for
example what would be the logic for
saying we're no longer going to tax
income but we're going to tax land that
people owned what would be the point of
that ok well the main argument is its
the ML V T is considered one of the most
efficient taxes and it's been my dad
vacated specifically by people like
built-ins Freeman and across because the
whole assumption is that no one really
owns land if that makes sense even when
you own land you still pay a tax on it
to the government so so it's your land
but libertarians like to say it's not
really yours if you have to pay a tax on
it
yeah yeah it's kind of like okay well
there are a lot of people right now who
are buying up land and not developing
the land so it's pretty much like a
system where people can put low-income
housing and landlords pretty much it's
what I consider a rent-seeking behavior
many landlords don't really actually
develop their land or make it a very
productive I mean it's also in regards
to the environment to you I'm a very
enviable holder let's let's take these
things one at a time because we're
throwing you're throwing in a lot of
things together let me in your situation
where we put in place we get rid of the
income
and put in place a land tax if you don't
own land or reduce Teresa I would not
not not a full abolishment you can
reduce income taxes and go after more
rent seeking behaviors you go I'm saying
I do yeah I'd have to look more at the
specific approach I just have to look at
more specifics and I wouldn't be able to
say you know maybe there's a proposal
like that that I would like but so far
they're replacing the income tax but
something else have not been
particularly appealing to me
historically it was founded in about the
19th century by this guy named Henry
George there's a book about it's called
progress in property great book but
there is also this guy in 1994 1997
his name was Fred Harrison he completely
modeled the entire boom-bust cycle that
led to the 2008 housing crisis and he
was also advocating for some sort of
form and these regards this view I mean
of course I watched your program the
other day and you're talking about how
Elizabeth Warren predicted it and
everything but at the same time this guy
he wrote an entire book about it in 1997
yes and many have written breaks yeah
previously as well I'll look into it and
I will report back to you how about that
Oh No thank you for sure I
great talking you love us yeah okay
thanks Bobby appreciate the phone call
thank you